Performance patterns
From common sources of inconvenience
For novice programmers and experts alike: threads.
I'm Joanna Smith.
Threads may be one of the biggest performance improvements
Which you can do but it will also drive you crazy.
Tom Sawyer explained the threads an ideal explanation in the past
When I needed to paint the fence.
Because when you have to do a whole bunch of things over and over again,
You call some friends to get it done quickly.
So in the case of accounts that take a long time,
Think about asking for reinforcements with threads.
It is enabled by running many execution threads
In your data set at the same time,
Reduces the total time required to complete the task.
With Android, threads become very important
Because the entire application runs on the main thread
Which is also called the User Interface Thread because it occurs.
When the user interface stops responding,
Users stop using your app.
So when you want to perform a complex procedure
In response to pressing a button, for example,
You will need to stay away from the main thread
Until the procedure ends
So the user can continue to interact with your application
Few things are worse than the terrible application response dialog box.
But integrate the threads into your system
Something that weak-hearted people do not do.
Because they will have to change their approach
With computational complexity and memory model
To be able to integrate the threads correctly.
So to avoid problems,
Use the Android window
Which is designed to help you.
You will be able to think carefully and carefully plan your application structure and flow
Determine if the thread should affect
On the user interface or completely hidden.
Helps APIs such as AsyncTask and Thread
On the management of work and prevent the suspension of your application.
But AsyncTask will also let you influence the user interface
When you want, for example, to display the progress dialog box.
So lose your own application
Find out if there are places where it stops responding
Or its response to user actions is much slower.
Then, separate all these additional actions from the main thread
But thoughtfully.
Changes are not made in an unplanned manner.
Because while threads may be scary,
It should not scare you.
What should really frighten is bad performance;
So you'll lose the rest of your Android Performance Patterns
Think about joining the G + forum for tips and help.
But above all, bother and gather your code instructions
Always remember that performance is important.